bootle cat podcast special guests in
here
that guy's on fire he's on fire right
now
one of my favorites pz is here Detroit's
in the building thank you brother I
appreciate you kale it's dope to see uh
this because I've been following you for
a long time obviously I've been tapped
in since before you got locked up and uh
it's super dope to see you catch this
hit record man
you know what I'm saying and now it
feels like everybody else is coming
around you know what I'm saying how do
you feel like because it's one thing to
have the catalog and to be able to go to
certain markets and pick up bags and and
to get those streaming checks but how
does it feel to have like a record like
a hit
it feels good because of course it feel
good because
I've been rapping so long exactly and
it's like I watched everybody like
and there's no disrespect everybody in
the D that like blew up I kind of had
like personal relationship with them
like
you know what I'm saying so I watched
everybody go I watched everybody music
take off from the root you know what I'm
saying I was right there with all of
them
and it had me kind of feeling like maybe
my music wasn't good enough you know
what I'm saying so I feel good to
finally be getting the recognition there
because I've been working hard for a lot
of years for sure man you've been
putting in work you know putting putting
so much catalog and obviously you know
the label free Rio uh you know I feel
like what you've been doing in building
um it's just dope to see everybody else
coming to the table now at the party I
guess you know what I mean and I also
feel like to the timing just for Detroit
is crazy right now because you catching
a hit at the same time that
feels like every label signing somebody
from Detroit oh yeah Detroit you got
Babyface Ray you got Icewear Vezzo you
got baby baby money TV baby Tron baby
Tron
um it's the list it's a lot a lot of
them it's a lot man everybody everybody
doing good